LAURA DELLA TORRE: Hi.
I'm Laura Della Torre.
I'm on the Developer
Marketing Team
on the Google Play
side of things.
Today, we've got a
special treat for you.
We know that we get a
lot questions, requests,
and wish list items
for how we can
help you grow your
business on Google Play.
I have a special treat.
We have some product
managers, we have our business
development folks,
and we're going
to have them give
a quick short intro
but then what we want
to do is we actually
want to throw the
questions out at you.
Here are the product managers.
This is a great opportunity for
you to get in what you need.
I get a lot of questions.
Do you have x?
Do you have y?
If you want your voices heard,
this is the place to be.
So with that, I am going
to go ahead and hand
the mic on over to Greg and
he'll introduced himself.
GREG HARTRELL: Hi.
I'm Greg Hartrell, the Lead
Product Manager for Google
Play games.
ELLIE POWERS: Hi.
I'm Ellie Powers.
I'm the Lead Product Manager
for Apps on Google Play.
DAN LAVELLE: Hi.
I'm Dan Lavelle, End
Developer Operations,
and I work with the folks
that support you day to day.
SERGE KASSARDJIAN:
I'm Serge Kassardijan.
I work in-- I lead up business
development for East Coast
Apps, Games, Partners.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKIHi.
I'm Brahim Elbouchiki.
I work on Payments, Search,
Discovery for Google Play.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Great.
So first thing we want
to do is throw out
some easy questions for you.
How many people, show of
hands, how many people
are making games?
OK.
The rest are apps?
Apps?
OK.
Wow.
OK, we got a good
apps folks here.
Um, let's start off with hmm.
Greg, what do you think?
Let's get the games
guys talking for a bit.
Let's ask them some questions.
What do you-- what do you want?
What kinds of things
are you looking
at building that you
want their input on?
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah, to open up
the floor looking for questions
around-- we build
this game network
that we call Google
Play Games which
helps enhance gameplay and
get your game discovered.
I think it'd be fascinating
to hear any questions that you
have around any
challenges integrating
those types of services or
getting your game discovered.
Would love to hear
any type of feedback
that you have in that area.
Maybe Ellie or Brahim,
you have other-- want
to add some texture to that?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI:
Do you want to answer
the question is that--
LAURA DELLA TORRE: What
do you want to know?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI: Oh, yeah.
One is just the
basic like what are
a few things we could do
to change your businesses
and make them and help them
grow and make your lives easier
on the areas that I work on
way, which are like commerce
and payments, search,
and discovery.
So how do you acquire users?
How can we help you
acquire them better?
How do you-- what do you think
of the organic acquisition
on the Play store?
What do you think
of monetization?
You know, how are
the trends looking?
So anything around
that would be awesome.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Here,
I'm going to go ahead
and I'll-- there you go.
AUDIENCE: Well, I can address
the monetization question.
So one of the
challenges of being
in the kids educational app
category is the monetization.
We're sitting on a lot of users,
we have over 30 million users.
But because only 2% of
them converts to paid,
that creates the limits--
that limits the monetization.
That's what the monetization is
limited, essentially 2%, right?
So if we are selling
our games to teach kids
how to learn their
letters and letters
A through E available on the
free version, the rest is paid.
Well, only 2% convert
and that's actually
considered pretty
good for-- compared
to even so our competitors.
So maybe, OK, we
can get the rate up
if we optimize things to 3%.
But it's still-- it's
a sad, it's a sad thing
that we should be
sitting on so many users
and have this kind
of monetization.
And another thing, another
interesting phenomena
that I'm noticing is
that it's almost like--
so that's as far as the upsell.
And as far as the
cross sell also,
70% of our users
download one app from us.
Now this one is paid.
So in terms of cross
sell from one paid app
to another, what we are
seeing it's about 70%
have just one app.
And that despite our
apps like literally
stacked at the top of
the educational category,
number one, number two,
number three, and so on.
So it's almost to
us, it almost seems
as if the user has x
amount of money to spend.
It's like they-- let's
say they have $10 a month
they are going to spend.
And no matter how many
apps you're offering,
that's just-- you can
be making more apps
but they still have the same
amount of money to spend.
And they have to spend it on
you and on your competitors.
So that has been a real problem.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI: Is
your app a paid app?
Or is it free with
in-app purchases?
AUDIENCE: So we have 15 apps.
And each one has--
there's a free app.
And there is a paid app that
has more letters or more
numbers or more activities.
That's the model right now.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI: OK.
So, I think the freemium
model definitely
tends to have far
fewer convert to buyers
than your actual users.
And the hope is that
your marginal costs,
so your incremental costs
of running the thing
is actually supported by such
a small number of buyers,
you might definitely
optimize and Ellie
might jump on this one, too,
by having the same app actually
have in-app purchases
in it so somebody
can enhance their experience.
I know a lot of schools
don't like that because they
want to have the "I want to
get the whole app going--"
AUDIENCE: Well, the school
thing is a separate conversation
because Google Play for
education right now,
I mean we've-- you
know, like I said,
we're at the top of
the education category
and we've made like so far like
exactly $1,000 in the Google
Play for Education.
So that's, again, not talking
main Google Play, just
Google Play for Education.
So that's still ramping up so
I'm not even that-- I'm not--
I'm not.
I'm being patient.
Obviously, it's
going to take time.
You know this is a
big endeavor that's
Google is undertaking
with that so I'm
going to wait for
that to take off.
But in Google Play, just
in regular Google Play,
we tried simply searching the
model to in-app purchases.
So simply having the
same content available
as in-app purchase
doesn't do anything.
In-app purchases
seemed to work when
you're playing an
arcade type games
and you're buying more lives
and you're buying more powers.
So that works.
But if you just take-- in a kid.
So essentially when your
customer's a kid and the buyers
are parents, so you
can't serve ads.
The conventional in-app
purchases don't do anything
and it's a-- no, it
is really a-- the only
model right now, vital model is
the one we are using right now,
which is limited.
Now subscription
would work if we
could have new content that
is being constantly released.
But that's not applicable.
So in the end, it's just a--
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI:
I want to talk
to you offline because I
think it feels like there's
a way for you to use in-app
for that, for your app as well.
Maybe we'll catch up offline.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Great.
Got a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is about the organic
discovery of apps and all.
And how does the installation
and uninstallation
impacts that?
So what do count as install?
Is it the download started
or the download CRC
done and finished?
What counts as an
install in Play?
Because we've seen
some discrepancies
when we look at our own database
because we have a registration.
So when we see the
registration and when
we look at the Play Store
count, there's some discrepancy.
And when we see--
because our apps syncs,
we see the number
of unique syncs.
What is an uninstall?
So how does that get in?
How do you measure
the uninstall?
And how does the uninstall
impacts the discoverability?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI:
I can take that one.
So I can't really
disclose the details
of how we're using
all these signals.
All I can tell you
is that they all
contribute to how the
organic discovery of your app
works, uninstalls, installs,
how much-- how long
is the install duration for?
There's a number of things.
We've posted a
video, actually, one
of the DevBytes about search
and discovery on Google Play.
So you can watch that.
But the second part
of your question
was around-- sorry--
uninstalls, right?
So installs definitely
really matter, right?
Because it's a signal about
whether is a user still engaged
with the application or not?
Have they-- ratings also
matter quite a bit, right?
So all of these
things are signals
that go into the overall model.
AUDIENCE: So why do you
consider uninstalls specifically
intent to uninstall or
somebody hasn't connected
to the internet for
like a fortnight
and count that app
as an uninstall.
Because what's
happening-- like the way--
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI: No, it has
to be a literal uninstall so--
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because the way it's
happening for me
is that my APK, for
some strange reason
end up on some third
party websites, OK.
And now these guys--
I have no way for them
to like upgrade to
the latest version.
And now these guys
are uninstalling.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI: But
if it wasn't distributed
through Play, it
doesn't matter, right?
AUDIENCE: No, but because
it has the same signature.
OK.
So when it uninstall, will
it imbed my discovery--
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI: It's
uninstalled only on the system,
only on the device.
If it's distributed
through a third party
website or somewhere, we--
AUDIENCE: No, no.
So they got the same APK from
Play Store, they can download
and then they basically
provided for like you know--
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI:
Let's take it offline
because I think it's specific
to what you're talking about.
But I don't think
that's the case.
AUDIENCE: So for example, if
I'm advertising an app in Asia,
because for me it's cheaper
20 cents per download,
around that.
And how does the search rankings
and organic rankings will be
mattering in the US?
Will that affect?
Are all of the
continents or countries
are independent in the
rankings section because yeah?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKI:
So, so I hope it's
to basically have
a store per user.
So each user has a
unique store that
is personalized and
tailored to them.
And so that would contribute.
So if your installs
are coming from Asia,
then we can understand that
this is a popular app in Asia.
And that would influence what
your growth is like in Asia.
It will also be
signaled in the US
but this is all weighted
in different ways.
But there is a signal of like
you're a popular app in Asia
because most of your
installs are in Asia.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: I
know that a lot of people
want to ask a bunch of questions
but this is a great opportunity
to get in your wish list.
What I would love
to do is let's have
one of you guys ask a
question of the audience
and let's get their input.
SERGE KASSARDJIAN: So one
of the big things for us,
we see a lot of people
invest a lot of time,
sources, people, money
into building apps.
And we always struggle
trying to understand
what your success metrics are.
So after the launch, after
something goes to market,
how do define successful and how
do you see success or failure?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we do invest
a lot into building apps.
I'm Rafael from
[INAUDIBLE] and we recently
launched on the
Android Play Store.
It was a great experience
because at first we
had some level of transparency
that we didn't have before
but to us, besides the usual
conversion, engagement,
and retention metrics that
are platform dependent,
I think the organic metric,
organic downloads are actually
the most important,
organic users really.
I think there's
something very powerful,
potential in the Store which
is the +1 recommendation,
which is basically the only App
Store that provides this kind
of layer.
Unfortunately, I
think we're really
missing the tools
to harness that.
So we were able to get a lot of
+1s from a lot of people but we
have no ability to see how does
it impact keywords or how does
it impact the scoreability in
the store in an accurate way.
And it would make sense
that only some users have
social circles on Google
Plus and for those people,
we should try to present
that in a better way
before there's just
a waste of time.
And does it impact different
metrics on the store?
Because organic is really
the important thing.
And organic, I think,
should be a common metric
between apps and the
store because if there
is organic downloads, it
means that the user is happy
and the app is happy.
And I think there is
nowhere close to the ability
to really look into that and
understand how it impacts
and how to optimize for
that in a meaningful way.
And that is, I would say,
in the area of the +1,
first and foremost.
But also in the
place for listing,
I think the ability to
test different versions
and look at different
combinations for maybe
different kinds of users.
I mean, we're-- there are many
different intents to download
an app and we should be able
to test different variances
of that.
And I think, I
would say these are
the two most important ones.
SERGE KASSARDJIAN: And
how much A/B testing
do you guys do across
the different versions
at the same time?
AUDIENCE: So we do that
actually quite a lot.
We use straight
roll out as well,
which is good for
some level of that.
But for the Play
Store, we try to do it.
We've even use some
external service that
is doing a proxy
for this testing
because it's difficult
to do on the store.
But we would like
to do much more
and it's just that the tooling
is just very limited to do so.
LAURA DELLA TORRE:
That actually,
and I will absolutely
get to that.
But I want to touch
on the A/B testing.
How many people are
using our A/B testing
in the developer console?
Very few.
How many people are interested
in doing beta testing?
OK.
All right.
You had something
you wanted to say?
AUDIENCE: So I'm [INAUDIBLE]
from Magma Mobile, a game
developer.
We've had 300 million downloads
of our games on Android.
And the biggest challenge
to us is retention.
And the matrix that we're
using is DAU over MAU
to really track their retention.
So I guess my
challenge to you guys
is what can you guys do
to really help us out
with retention?
So in terms of suggestions
and things like that,
there's a few ideas, like for
example, the Google Play Game
App is too static these days.
And I think it should
surface more data.
I mean, really quickly,
you could pick up
that a game is 50% off
and there's an opportunity
or there are some quests
or leader boards or quests
that about to
expire and you want
to send them back to the game.
So that's one of my suggestions.
And also to what extent you guys
can work with the Google Now
team to surface some
game data on Google Now
because these days people
are using Google Now a lot
because it's updated
data, it's tailored data.
And to what extent it can also
apply to all their app activity
on a daily basis?
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Thank you.
GREG HARTRELL: This
is music to my ears
because one of the reasons why
a lot of our game services exist
is to solve many of the problems
that you're just describing.
I'll reiterate
some of the things
we announced yesterday
because I think
that they match what some of
the recommendations you have.
So we launched a couple
new game services,
one's called Save Games.
This is not just
blobs storage but what
we do is we ask developers
to send us a screen
shot and metadata
that we surface
inside of the Play
Games Apps and inside
of other experiences.
And the way that
we think about it
is we run into this
in mobile, everybody
has constant partial attention.
So they go on vacation,
they forget about the game
that they were
playing and there's
nothing there to remind
them coming back.
And there's a sea
of icons there.
What's nice about
Save Games is if you
show a very vivid
image of the last time
that they play the game
or maybe the character
that they're working
on inside of the game,
it acts as a digital bookmark
to remind them saying, "Hey, I
was playing your game."
Yeah, I walked away
from it for a week
but I remember that I
left off at level five.
The description of the
Save Games tells me that.
So we're starting to add
aspects of games services that
build that relationship
with your users.
The other one that you
may or may not be aware of
is we launched another
service that we call Quests.
And Quests literally
is a service
that drives time-based
challenges, in the vein of what
you just described, it's
all game activity based.
So by sending telemetry
into this Quests service,
you're able to configure
time-based challenges
like a weekend, I don't
know, zombie killing
fest, or whatever
your game is into.
And you're able to constantly
re-engage users and most
automatically send
notifications to those users
as the Quests expire.
So I would encourage
all developers
who are interested in
just boosting retention
these services
including multiplayer
achievements in leader boards.
We're seeing developers show us
20%, 30%, 40% bumps in day two
retention and number in
sessions played per day, just
by virtue of integrating
and doing a very well, very
good design around them.
Oh, sorry.
Google Now?
I think as we get
more signals and we
like to take
advantage of the data
that we have at Google to build
better user experiences, that's
a really fascinating idea.
I think that we'll
take it to heart
and we'll talk with
the Google Now team.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Great.
I think we got another product
requests coming over here.
AUDIENCE: Not really
a product request
but I'm Josh with OpenTable.
One of the biggest--
GREG HARTRELL: Fan of your app.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
One of the greatest
challenges we've
had with our latest update
is the new permissions.
So every time somebody
updates the app,
they get bombarded with
all the things that we do
and there was an
attempt recently
to re-categorize this
permissions in such a way that
make them seem less arcane
but unfortunately, it
had other side effects.
So for example, for us,
we have a permission
that we have to
ask for it to use
Google Maps in our app, that's
called Read, Write, External
Storage or Write
External Storage.
That's for caching
of the map tiles.
And unfortunately,
it's rolled up
under Read, Video, Files,
and Music or whatever it is.
And so all of our users are
rating our app very negatively
because they think that
we're stealing their files,
reading their files, doing
all these sorts of things.
And it's something that's
really avoidable if were either
able to explain in-line
with the permission,
saying why do we use this
permission or some other way
that they're not just
rolled up to seem more
intrusive than
they actually are.
Thanks.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
tanks for the feedback.
I guess just to give a
little bit of background
on the change.
One of the things we had
noticed with a lot of users
was that users, in the majority,
were simply not reading
permissions at all
because it was just
sort of this long list of
very obscure technical words.
And so a lot of people had no
idea what they were actually
granting access to when
they install applications.
So by giving little icons
and sort of grouping together
the different types
of permissions,
we wanted to make people more
aware of the capabilities
that we are granting.
And I guess
definitely what you're
running into is that
how do I put this,
I guess when you get that,
Read, Write, External
Storage permission, you
actually did have the ability
to do exactly what
it now describes.
But your app is obviously
not doing that, right?
Not reading the user's
photos and things like that.
So I think the changes that we
made or something that we hope
are going to get more people
interested in permissions
and making them more
aware of what's possible.
But we're definitely
thinking a lot more long term
about what would a better, more
comprehensive change look like.
So, I think the idea
of explaining, allowing
a developer to explain why the
permissions are being requested
is a really interesting one.
It's certainly something we've
thought about on the team.
So I guess what I would say
is just that we are planning
to make more additional
changes and we
hope that by getting more users
aware of what's happening,
they will pay more attention
to what capabilities
they are granting.
But I totally get that
this can be really painful
if the actual access
that the user is granting
is actually greater
access then what maybe
your app is actually doing.
Your app may have the ability
to read the user photos
but you may not
actually be doing that.
But it can be tricky
because if you
say a phrase like "Read, Write,
External Storage" to my mom
or something like
that, she's going
to have no idea what that means.
But actually, if she does
grant that permission
to an application, it could
actually read her photos
and edit them.
So even though
OpenTable obviously
wouldn't do that, I'm a huge
customer and huge fan of,
made many, many restaurant
reservations through it.
I think, just definitely know
that this is an area that we're
thinking about on a weekly
basis, within the team,
and we're trying to
figure out more ways
to balance making users
aware of the capabilities
an application has
access to, and also
to make sure the developers
have a good experience as well.
So thanks for the feedback.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Great.
Other product requests?
Maybe something from developer
console or search or Store?
AUDIENCE: It's Store as well.
This is fairly simple.
I'm wondering if there's going
to be any sort of a supported
API for the data and the
use case I'm thinking about
is now that native ads are--
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Could you
repeat that a little louder?
A request for what API?
AUDIENCE: In API for
Store listing data.
And in particular, I'll
give you a use case.
So as native ads get
more and more popular,
it'd be nice to do
something like show the star
rating next to the
ad, in the screen.
ELLIE POWERS: OK, so
just so I understand.
The API you're
talking about would
be something for making ads?
I didn't quite understand that.
AUDIENCE: Just
attributes on the apps
that are listed in Google Play.
So for instance, OpenTable
star rating 4.5 or whatever
it is, if I see through
a native ad listing,
I have an ad here to show
in my stream for OpenTable,
it'd be nice to show 4.5 stars
and know that it's right.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: OK.
I think what their request is.
A request is probably
for our ads team,
specifically, because
they're look--
you're talking about
ads-- yeah, but you
want to be able to retrieve
information about ads,
though right?
AUDIENCE: Information about apps
that are-- retrieve information
about apps that
are in Google Play.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
totally get that.
I'm just trying
to understand what
you'd be doing with it
because actually, when
you mentioned ads--
LAURA DELLA TORRE:
What's the use case?
How do use it?
ELLIE POWERS: When
you mentioned ads,
we actually have the most
standard format on AdMob
is like the name of
app, number of star
rating, that sort of thing.
So I'm trying to understand
what you'd want to do.
AUDIENCE: No, I get you.
I'm thinking in the context
of native mobile ads.
So for instance, if I get
native ads through InMobi,
as an example, so I've
got a package name,
it'd be nice to
get the star rating
and know that it's right,
as opposed to whatever
maybe the advertiser put in.
ELLIE POWERS: Well, that's
an interesting suggestion.
I hadn't heard about
exactly exposing that API.
Cool.
Yeah, thanks for the suggestion.
LAURA DELLA TORRE:
All right, panelists.
What else do you want to know?
Is there anything specific
you guys are thinking about
that you want feedback on?
DAN LAVELLE: Sure.
So has anyone in the audience
contacted Support before?
Issues using the
console or yeah?
So what we want
to know primarily
is what's effective for you
in terms of contacting us,
be it the end of the
channels you contact us
through or the
content that we host?
And what are your experiences?
What suggestions do you have so
that we can make better enable
you as you're either
triaging issue or you're
trying to-- the player app?
How can we help there?
LAURA DELLA TORRE: First of all,
I haven't-- a show of hands,
how many people are developers
that would be looking
for technical help?
OK.
And how many folks that are
more on the business side, maybe
looking for some
marketing assistance?
OK.
I want to know who, what
everybody else does here.
I want your job.
OK.
Anybody want to comment
on the support channels
or how we can help you?
I think, really for us,
we want to understand
what is the best way
to get you information.
Because I'd be willing to
bet, from those developers,
how many people are
using Stack Overflow
to get their questions answered?
Yeah, that's what I thought.
That's what I thought.
What I'm very
curious about is-- we
do have a variety of
different features for you.
Is there something we
can do to help answer
those questions for you, whether
they be technical or business?
AUDIENCE: This is
completely selfish
but I'll be completely selfish.
I've been trying to put up
a Jango app on App Engine.
And of course, it appears
now but it changed.
And there's great instruction
for writing it from scratch
but I want to take
something that's
more thoroughly
developed like mezzanine,
which is built on top of Jango.
Can't find any place to
get started with that.
And so all the mappings
are kind of screwy.
And it should be a fairly
straightforward thing
to do but it's not.
And also between the
change to Compute Engine
and some of this
containerization,
I'm completely lost
where to get started.
LAURA DELLA TORRE:
Where would you
like to go get that information?
AUDIENCE: Any old
website. [INAUDIBLE].
LAURA DELLA TORRE:
OK, so there's
some standard documentation.
Anybody else?
Anybody else have--
want to know where
they would get
technical support?
Maybe some business?
OK.
Yep.
Totally understand.
Absolutely.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'd like to
add something that is not
about support with Google
but support with our users.
So it's excellent
that you can reply
in the reviews,
that's really good.
And what about making
a threaded replies?
We see that users for when they
have to give us some permission
really have to, really like
to look into those replies
and reviews.
And most times, when
you're actually reactive
with comments, you
reply to review
and then the person who wrote
the review in the first place
changes it as a
means to an answer.
So it doesn't make sense.
So every time there is a
reply, that is quick enough
for the first user to
actually reply to the reply,
you have comments that just
don't really don't make sense.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
thanks for the feedback.
It was definitely something
we had thought about,
which was how far into a forum
do we want our reviews to go?
We decided we did want to
have a reply as unique way
to allow that direct interaction
between developers and users.
We're definitely aware
that has some limitations.
On the other hand,
we aren't sure
that we really want to
create a discussion forum.
So I think we're kind of in
this intermediate position
right now where we're
aware that it's not perfect
as it is but we're
not sure we really
want to go into a full-on
multi-threaded forum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ELLIE POWERS: It says, sorry.
Can you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
just add a tag that
says "Answered"
or "Reviewed" just
to know to read it differently.
ELLIE POWERS: OK.
Yeah, I think that's actually
could be a good suggestion.
Yeah, thanks for that.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Great.
Some more feedback here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
I'm [INAUDIBLE], I'm
one of the owners
of an app developer from
Australia called b2cloud.
We're actually a
service provider.
So we build applications
for many other businesses.
So we ourselves don't have a
huge presence on the Play Store
but rather always
encourage our customers
to be creating
their own Play Store
accounts to be
releasing their apps on.
So we don't have really strong
relationships with Google,
although we'd really like to
have stronger relationships.
We've got some
contacts there but it
seems like we can't get as
much traction as perhaps larger
developers who've got
their own Play Store
accounts with a significant
number of users who would
typically attract a little
more attention from you guys.
How are we able to better
connect, stay ahead, be
able to get what's
coming up, what
are the sort of
things that you want
to be able to see in your apps
that we can be encouraging
our customers and that we
can be suggesting features
to be including in our
applications for our customers?
SERGE KASSARDJIAN: Yeah, so.
So we knew we work
with-- and I think
it's been primarily
in the US but we
want to expand it to
Australian and other regions
with development firms who are
building for their clients.
We provide them materials
and we show them
what our best practices
are so that they
can become a channel
for us, so that you
could distribute
these best practices.
So--
LAURA DELLA TORRE:
But I hear you.
I think it's a good point.
Thank you for the feedback.
Maybe there's something we can
do from a program perspective
and give you visibility
amongst other developers
or figure out
exactly where brands
go to get their
development firm support.
So thank you very much for that.
We have exactly one
minute left so I
am going to turn it
over to you guys,
if you have anything else
that's burning on your mind.
Is there something you guys
are thinking about doing
and want some quick feedback?
ELLIE POWERS: So I guess
I would ask all of you
how do you currently gain
distribution for your apps?
What's working the best?
And what can we do
to help enhance it?
LAURA DELLA TORRE: Super short.
AUDIENCE: My favorite topic.
So thanks for your
presentation yesterday
when you mentioned matchmaking,
that made me think about that.
Another presentation
I went to yesterday
talked about all kinds of
different contextual signals
that people are going to
be using for Google Now
in these kinds of devices.
And I was thinking well why
is the Play Store so limited
in the signals that it's taking
in from its users, right?
You've got a search term
but that's it, right?
That might work great for games
or other kind of blockbuster,
maybe short-term
engagement apps.
But for something
more niche, long-term,
like an OpenTable or that
the company I work with,
GetYourGuide, which
is a travel app.
Find things to do
when you travel.
We really want the
clue of somebody
when they're in a city that's
not their home or these other,
when they've got an
appointment, all these
are the contextual things that
are being considered for Now.
Are they on the roadmap
for Google Play?
ELLIE POWERS: I guess
we'll say that we're
worth thinking about a
lot of the same questions.
And I'd love to hear
from another developer.
So thanks for the feedback.
LAURA DELLA TORRE: So here's
what we're going to do.
We have to wrap-up,
just because we
have another panel
coming on here.
Thank you guys so
much for your time.
We were going to
be around here, out
of the way of the next
session coming through.
But thank you so much.
Really appreciate your
help and your feedback
and please keep it coming.
Thank you.